Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the podcast.
You guys are in for quite a treat today,
because my guest is none other than the great Alex Honnold
returning for his second appearance on the show,
his first being almost exactly three years ago.
That was episode 351,
if you missed it on the first go around.
Most of all of you are familiar at this point
with Alex's death and gravity-defying, ropeless ascent
of El Capitan on the big screen.
That was a feat that landed the film "Free Solo"
a documentary Oscar, of course,
and also cemented Alex in the history books
as truly one of the greatest athletes of all time.
This conversation picks up where our last one left off
to explore some of Alex's life experiences
and interests post "Free Solo" as an adventurer,
as the co-host
of the recently released Climbing Gold podcast,
also as an environmentalist at the helm
of the Honnold Foundation and many other topics.
It's such a good one,
definitely quite a bit different
from other conversations with Alex
that you might have enjoyed over the years.
So without further ado, let's do the thing.
This is me and the great Alex Honnold.
Cool man. Are we good?
All good.
Oh, we're rolling. Excellent, man.
Oh, we're recording?
Yeah, we're already recording.
Good to see you.
Yeah, good to see you.
Do I need to worry about where anything is or?
I don't think so.
Just worry about where the mic is,
But you know that,
because now you're a professional podcaster.
Well, I don't really do the technical side of it.
(Rich laughs)
You do have to talk into a mic though?
I bring nothing to the team
except for the witty banter with the guests.
Well, I listened to like the first little,
like the little trailer thing and it's all,
you do the little like, "Hey, is this thing on?"
Or like, "Let's do take two" or whatever.
I actually, I don't know if I've heard it yet.
You haven't, oh, you haven't even listened
to your own podcast yet?
Well, I've been gone.
But the idea, I mean, it's called Climbing Gold.
The idea, was the idea at the inception
that it was gonna be more
about the Olympics and then that had to pivot a little bit?
Yeah, exactly.
The idea for the podcast was to focus on the road
to the Olympics, sort of the buildup,
because going into 2020,
it felt like climbing was having a huge moment.
It's funny, I'm on the board
of a climbing gym organization as well,
and it felt like it was this huge moment for climbing,
'cause climbing is in the Olympics
for the first time.
And it's like going off.
Obviously COVID changed that quite a bit.
And so when we started talking about doing a podcast,
it made sense to explore sort of the history
and the future of climbing during this moment.
And then when the Olympics got pushed because of COVID,
we sort of went forward with it anyway,
mostly because we felt
like there were still interesting stories to tell.
But so now we're still doing,
I think we're doing 20 episodes,
and the second 10 are focused more on the lead up
to the Olympics, which we'll be doing this summer.
So it's sort of like the history
and the untold stories and the kind of things that happen.
Because so much of climbing occurs outside
of the spotlight of the media completely.
Well, and so much of climbing history has occurred
before there was media to some extent, you know,
before things were easily recorded or digified and shared.
And so there are just so many classic climbing stories
that are sort of lost to history a little bit.
So it's pretty fun to uncover some
of those and share some.
So did you have to be like a journalist
and go and find these people
and talk to them and have them tell their stories?
Like a very unprofessional journalist,
like a very unskilled journalist.
A podcaster.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Yeah, quote podcaster.
Let's not confuse
journalism with podcasting.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
No, it's not fair to say
that we did any journalism,
but we did seek out interesting guests in different spaces.
And I think the thing that we're trying to sort of add
to the space of climbing podcasting as it were
is a little bit more editing and a little bit more
of a thematic focus, like, you know, having multiple voices
from different people in the same episode
talking about specific themes
to sort of help educate about certain aspects of climbing
and share a little bit about where climbing has come from.
And your cohost has, he did another podcast, right?
Dirtbag Diaries or something like that?
Yeah, my cohost is Fitz Cahall
who's an actual professional podcaster.
He actually knows what he's doing.
He's the one that sent me the microphone that I use
and told me how to set it up and how to use everything.
Yeah, he's the one that really...
And I mean, really the whole reason the podcast exists
is because he approached me
about working on a project together.
And I was like, "Oh, he's the perfect person to work with,
"because he already knows how to do it."
Was there an original plan before the Olympics got pushed
that you would go to Tokyo and be,
make covering the climbing competition there
part of the podcast?
No, so fun story.
I am actually supposed to be going
to Tokyo to do commentary for the Olympic Channel.
So technically I have a contract already
with the actual Olympic Committee or whatever to go
do commentary for climbing.
To do that.
And so part of doing the podcast was
because I personally felt
like it would be a great way to learn how to commentate.
Because I don't know anything about sports commentation,
but I figured I'd learn before the Olympics.
And so the podcast seemed
like a really great way to get to know some
of the backstory, meet some of the competitors,
learn about their process.
And you know, so as it turns out,
we haven't focused on that so far,
because the Olympics got pushed.
So we just decided to kind of wait and see on that side.
But it's almost better this way,
because this way the episodes that we have recorded
are like the deeper backstory
and then it allows us to sort of set the stage
so that when we get to the Olympic side of the podcast
there's already a good context for it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So somebody who doesn't know anything can listen to that,
and then by the time the competition starts,
they feel like they have a context-
Exactly.
For everything that's happening.
That's exactly the hope is that someone
who's interested in the outdoors
and has maybe climbed once or, you know,
just sort of a general interest could listen to the podcast,
understand and appreciate the stories
and still feel like they learned something important
about the sport.
How do you feel in general
about climbing being in the Olympics?
I'm pretty into it.
I mean, there are a lot of climbers,
particularly older climbers
that are sort of crusty about it
that think that it's, you know, degrades the sport
in some way or sort of,
or really the fact that I'm calling climbing a sport.
I think some climbers would take umbrage with that.
Because a lot of people consider climbing more
of a lifestyle or more of like an adventure.
But you know, I come from a gym climbing background.
I grew up going to a climbing gym.
So I've always thought of climbing
at least in some part as a sport.
And so I'm excited about the Olympics.
I mean, I'm psyched to go.
I'm psyched to see it.
I saw a rendering of the venue.
It looked incredible.
I haven't seen it yet.
It's like this huge like amphitheater
with the walls and like, you know, the seating.
Cool.
I don't know what it's gonna be like
now that they're restricting kind of attendance, right?
Like if you're a foreigner you can't go or-
I think there'd be enough domestic attendance
that it'll still be crazy.
I mean, climbing in Japan is a big deal.
Is it?
Yeah, it's really popular.
And Japanese competitors have sort of dominated
the World Cup scene for the last few years,
which I think is maybe part of the reason
that climbing is in the Olympics in Tokyo this year is
because I think the host country has some influence on that.
But yeah, Japanese competitors will likely do very well
and will likely have enthusiastic support
from the home crowd.
Well, what's interesting about it now being a sport,
where there's the controversy of it being a sport
to begin with and then there's controversy around
how they're constructing the competition, right?
Like you have these three events essentially,
like speed, boulder, lead,
and it's kind of your cumulative score
across those three disciplines that determines your ranking.
Yeah, that's exactly it.
And so it's a slightly confused system in some ways.
I mean, I think it's fine.
It skews towards doing it fast though, right,
which is kind of a weird thing, isn't it?
No, sort of.
It's like, should we just dive into it?
It's like slightly complicated.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, I mean, this is like inside baseball,
but this is interesting,
and especially since the Olympics are going to be happening
and we're all gonna be watching this.
And actually, so yeah, I'll dive into
like the nitty gritty of climbing scoring.
But I think what's interesting about it is
that you can kind of apply this to all sports,
because the decathlete or the biathlon or whatever,
like to some extent any sport you see
in the Olympics is being arbitrarily scored
in a way that the competitors
or at least the organizing committees have agreed upon.
And so, you know,
any sport that you're watching is slightly arbitrary.
I mean, other than just the purely elemental swimming
or running, like strictly for speed.
Other than that,
you're always getting into formatting issues
and it's just interesting.
And so with climbing, like you said,
it's the combination of the three disciplines.
It's a combined format.
But it's actually, you multiply the scores in them.
And so it sort of disproportionately weights excellence
in specific categories in a weird way.
You know what I mean?
In theory if someone's average,
if someone's pretty good at all three disciplines,
like they get fourth in all three,
you think that's great,
but it actually, they would do worse
than someone who was a great speed climber
but not as good as the other two disciplines.
So it's this kind of weird formatting style
that favors dominance in one category.
And that's one of the reasons
that a lot of climbers have complained
about speed climbing being included,
because most people focus on the other two aspects.
Most people focus on bouldering and lead climbing
and sort of exclude speed calming.
And so by combining them all
into this combined format it's suddenly forced
these otherwise elite competitors
to sort of learn this new sport,
that they didn't really want.
Right, like trying to tell a middle distance runner
that suddenly they have to be 100-meter sprinter.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, that's not a, yeah.
It's like telling a middle distance runner
that all of a sudden they're gonna have to do
a 100-meter sprint,
and that's gonna count into their score.
And they're like physiologically
it's different things, you know?
And more than the physiological difference,
there's also a skill difference with the speed climbing.
'Cause the speed wall
for climbing is like a specific track basically.
It's a specific sequence of movements.
So you do have to learn that track,
like learn how to jump between the holds well.
So it's made for TV,
because you would have two people right next to each other
scurrying up the wall.
But that's the thing.
As fast as possible.
Me personally-
In like five seconds or something.
Yeah, exactly.
That's exactly, yeah, five seconds up a 15-meter wall.
It looks completely insane.
Yeah, so for me as a spectator, I think it's awesome.
Like it's easy to understand.
It's incredibly, it's an incredible display of athleticism.
Like when you see people with speed climb in an elite level
you're like, "That guy is a good athlete,"
just hands down.
And you know, I can understand
why the climbing competitors aren't into it,
but I'm like I don't know.
From an outside perspective, it looks amazing.
It's great for TV.
It's easy to understand.
And I kind of like the well-rounded, you know,
the fact that it forces the competitors
to be well-rounded.
It's like a holistic-
Rather than just making
like swimming or track and field
where these would each be individual events.
That's part of the thing is
that because climbing is an exhibition sport in 2020,
the sport is only allowed one metal.
And so that's why they did a combined format,
because that way,
had they just excluded speed climbing altogether,
that's not fair to the speed athletes.
But with only one metal, like how are you gonna do it?
So they just combined it into one.
Yeah.
So the other one is how far you can climb,
like the height that you can climb
in a six-minute interval or something like that?
No, so lead climbing and bouldering both basically,
so lead climbing is climbing a taller wall with a rope.
Bouldering is climbing a short wall without a rope.
And both of those are basically just measures
of pure difficulty.
So the bouldering, the boulder routes
that you have to climb are incredibly difficult.
And so they're like a test of max physical power.
So it's almost like power lifting
but with an incredible amount of gymnastic skill
and technique built into it.
And then the lead climbing wall is the same thing
but on a higher, you know,
because you're climbing higher,
it's a more of an endurance test basically.
So are any of them scored like diving though
with like numbers, or is it all on a watch?
No, they are scored with numbers,
but they're scored by numbers
because you basically count how many holds
up the route you make it.
So if the lead route is, you know, 50 holds long,
like 50 hand movements up,
your score is basically which hand movement you made it to
before you fall off.
But in general, if you see somebody successfully climb
from the bottom to the top, they're basically gonna win.
Like if someone makes it to the top,
you're like, "That guy's the champion."
He's the dude.
Who are the standouts?
Are there any runaway favorites here?
Yeah, yeah, there are a few.
Careful.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Exactly, I'm like, "Well."
Okay, so there's, I mean this is a real test
of my future Olympic commentating.
Yeah, here you go.
Let's just say that by August,
I will be much better versed in this.
So the three for men,
the three that come to mind right now
that are obvious standouts
are a Japanese man named Tomoa Narasaki
who dominated World Cup scene,
has incredible boulder
but also happens to be a very good speed climber.
So he kind of has this leg up in the combined format
where he can really win
in any of the three disciplines,
which makes him incredibly competitive.
And then there's Adam Ondra,
who's a Czech climber.
He's the Czech guy.
From the Czech Republic
who is arguably the best climber in the world.
He's pushed the standards of difficulty twice now,
like breaking into new categories
of difficulty for climbing.
And he's also repeated all the hardest walls in the world
and he's an incredible climber.
And he basically won all the World Cups
that he entered last year.
So I mean he's, or the year before last,
since they kind of canceled the COVID season.
But incredible climber, not a great speed climber,
sort of a self-described poor speed calmer,
which is ironic because he actually climbs very, very fast,
but he's just not good at the sport of speed climbing.
I mean, which is that's where all this stuff gets so weird,
because any casual climber looking at Adam Ondra climb
would be like, "Wow, he's so fast."
But then when it comes to speed climbing,
he just doesn't quite sprint fast enough.
It's like, it's so weird.
I think that over time though
once this becomes institutionalized
as an Olympic sport going forward
that young people who get enthusiastic about this
are gonna be doing almost all of their training
and learning in an indoor climbing wall.
What is the relationship between outdoor climbing
and kind of how you,
I mean, I know you do a lot of indoor climbing,
but essentially you're an outdoor climber?
Yeah, I'm essentially an adventurer.
By the standards of Olympic competition,
I'm not even a climber,
like I'm not even climbing at the difficulty
that these competitors warm up on basically.
But your relationship to climbing is one of adventure
and outdoors more than it is about indoor climbing?
Yeah, though I bridge it a little bit,
because I came from the indoor world.
I still love climbing indoors.
I still train in a similar way to competitors
but just at a much lower level.
But at least I'm still trying to do the same things.
But yeah, it is interesting.
I mean, and that's a big part of what we get into
in the podcast talking about in Climbing Gold
is this contrast between adventure and athleticism
and like where is the sport going?
Because like you said, people that get into it now
get into it in the gym and train indoors.
And I mean, it's just interesting
that an Olympic climber
could potentially never climb outdoors.
And then even more interesting
when you think that the history of rock climbing
sort of branches off from classical mountaineering
and people summiting peaks in the Alps and things like that.
And when you think that an Olympic rock climber nowadays
could have never even hiked up a mountain outside,
never even gone hiking.
Just divorced from that entire tradition.
Yeah, which I'm not saying that's good or bad,
but it's just interesting to see how the sport
has sort of splintered over time.
Yeah, it's cool that it's in there though.
And I guess there's,
when you look at Tokyo, there's karate,
skateboarding, surfing.
Yeah, totally.
The Olympics have changed quite a bit.
As they should.
It's cool.
I mean, the Olympics should reflect the times, I think.
And you know, in like the what '40s or '50s,
the Olympics included mountaineering.
They gave metals-
I didn't know that.
For mountaineering back in the day.
Wow.
You know, when you think of old school,
like the first ascent of the Eiger and things like that,
like classic mountains in Europe,
like those received Olympic metals, some.
Oh, I didn't know that.
And you know, and that went away.
That feels like a story you should tell in the podcast.
Yeah, we haven't gotten into it, but we probably will.
Cool. When does the podcast launch?
I think the podcast-
At the end of the month?
Yeah, I think at the end of the month.
So I think the 26th of March is the first episode,
but honestly, I'm uninvolved with the whole launch.
Come on.
You're the host though.
No, but I'm the unskilled host.
Everybody's got a podcast. Come on.
Just embrace it.
It's been fun though, because you know,
so many of our guests,
so many of the people I get to talk to
are personal heroes of mine from childhood,
people whose films I watched
or books I read or whose posters I had in my room,
things like that.
And so it's fun to be able to talk to them
about how they got into climbing
and what it means to them and just hear some
of their opinions about where the sport's going.
Because so many of them, I'm like, "That's my hero."
That's cool.
What do you think this whole thing is
that I've created here?
Totally, totally.
It's like the ultimate excuse to like call up cool people
and talk to them.
Yeah, learn from smart people.
And then you get to share that.
Imagine yourself, you know, young Alex at age 12
if a resource like that had been available to you,
like be the person that you needed
when you were that young person
searching for the thing for you.
I mean, that is cool.
And it's interesting because I think a big part
of what made me somewhat successful as a climber
in my life was the fact that I had access
to a climbing gym earlier than most.
And the gym, the climbing gym that I was going to had,
it had a little gear shop built-in.
It had this little video display constantly going
with certain climate films.
So you'd always see like certain climbing films going,
old school VHS.
You're like, "This is awesome."
Super inspiring.
I'd be climbing
and then I'd like read all the climbing magazines
and watch the films.
And, you know, to have that opportunity as a young person
is a big part of what allowed me to become a decent climber.
Yeah, and nowadays people have that, you know,
exponentially more of that, like more access to information,
more climbing footage available to them.
Yeah, it's cool.
And they've way better facilities,
like way better gyms.
The gyms seem to be ubiquitous these days.
Yeah, and not just more common but just better,
better lit, more open, cleaner,
like nicer, better holds, better setting,
like higher quality training facilities,
better pads, like better flooring, which is a big deal.
You know, I broke my arm in the gym when I was a kid.
Not so much because the flooring was bad,
but that kind of thing does factor in.
If you can safely climb in a,
like basically modern gyms are just safe.
And so you can climb,
you can push yourself super hard physically
with no risk of injury.
When you were doing the "Free Solo" tour,
I mean, it would be, you would share
like in every city that you would go to for the tour.
It was all about like where's the climbing gym
and like the workout that day
before the screening or whatever.
I've sampled like almost every gym in the country.
You must have been in every climbing gym in America.
Yeah, it feels like it,
but actually there's so many gyms in American now
that I've probably sampled a tiny percentage actually.
But it is true that every major city
in the country I've sampled the gym.
'Cause I typically would land.
I would go from the airport straight to the gym.
I would train.
I'd take a shower at the gym.
I would go straight to the venue,
do whatever event I was supposed to do
and then basically either go to a hotel
or go back to the airport.
But it's like, gyms have always felt
like a second home to me almost.
I walk into a climbing gym anywhere
and I'm like, "Ah, home sweet home."
I take your shoes off.
I want around, I dump my stuff everywhere.
But it has to be complicated with you now,
because if you just want to go and get a workout in,
you're gonna have to be a bit of a politician
for a while first.
Depends, depends.
You know, you wear your hood.
You keep your head down and just like climb.
To some extent, it's always a little bit of a scene.
But on the other hand, any gym in the country,
I mean everyone's there to do the same thing as you.
It is nice because you're all just there to climb together.
So when you get past the initial, like,
"Oh, what are you doing here?
"That's crazy. Can I take a picture?"
Ultimately you're like,
"Let's just session all these boulders together."
Because it's like we're all just there to do same thing.
Well, it's been a crazy couple of years for you.
The first time that you did the show,
we talked about the "Free Solo" climb,
but it was before the movie came out.
You remember that?
Yeah, yeah.
So I just remember thinking that I had a grip
on what it is exactly that you had done
and feeling confident that I understood it, (laughs)
and then you invited me to the premiere,
I remember, in Beverly Hills that screening.
And I watched the movie and I was like,
"Oh, I didn't understand it at all."
Like, I'm sure I still don't.
But the movie took it quite a bit further
in terms of getting me to fully grok
what had actually happened.
And then of course, you know, your story's well told
with everything that happened with the movie.
And you went on this crazy press tour
and did eight bazillion interviews.
And I'm sure completely talked out on this movie.
So I wanna talk about other stuff today,
but before we kind of move off of "Free Solo,"
I mean, in the wake of being so exhaustively interviewed
about that, do you feel like there's anything left to say
or anything left unsaid or anything, you know,
looking back on it that you feel like people misunderstood
about the movie or you
or is it just your time for the next chapter?
No, I think it's all pretty well-
It's been said.
Yeah, well, I mean,
I think part of why the film did so well is
that it is an incredibly honest look
at the process leading up to free soloing El Cap.
So I don't know, I've got nothing but positive...
It's like the media tour around it was crazy
and like going to the Oscars was crazy
and meeting Prince William or whatever,
because we won a BAFTA.
So like you're in the UK, like meeting royalty or whatever.
Like it's all totally crazy whirlwind tour,
but I can still look back on it and be happy
about the whole thing, you know?
'Cause I am, you know, understandably proud
of free soloing El Cap.
It was something very difficult
that I worked hard for, that I'm proud of.
And I think the film reflected that really well
and very honestly.
And so I'm like proud of the film,
I'm proud of the whole deal.
It's like, it's cool.
It was a phenomenon though.
I mean, everybody was talking about this movie.
For a documentary to break out like that
was just extraordinary.
Yeah, I mean, I don't, you know,
I was like so in it that I can't really say.
I was just surviving the tour.
It was like such a whirlwind.
But no, now looking back on it
with a little bit of perspective a few years away,
I'm like, "What a life experience,
"what a crazy whirlwind."
Crazy, man.
I mean, before the movie was made,
I joked that all I wanted was to see El Cap on IMAX,
just because El Cap to me is the most meaningful wall
in the world.
It's like the most beautiful, iconic face.
And to see it on the biggest possible screen,
it was like, that's cool.
And you know, sure enough, "Free Solo" showed on IMAX
and I got to see the movie on IMAX a couple of times.
And I was like, "This is so awesome."
(laughs) You love it.
You know, it's just, it's cool.
I was like, oh, we did the wall justice.
We did, you know, we did Yosemite justice.
It was like, I'm pretty proud of that.
And you did the world of climbing justice.
I mean, it was so effective
in introducing the magnitude of what you do to the world
and what's so kind of cherished about the community.
Or maybe too effective because then everyone
that doesn't know anything about climbing, they're like,
"So do you use a rope?"
And you're like, "Yeah, mostly use of rope.
"It's just this one crazy movie like happened to,"
'cause I know a lot of my serious climbing friends,
their families watched the movie and then they're like,
"Is that what you're doing?"
And they're like, "No, no, that's not what I'm doing."
And that's not even what I'm mostly doing,
because I'm typically climbing with partners
and training and just like climbing normally.
But obviously the documentary is focused entirely
on this, you know, this one sort of quixotic goal.
But you know, even that,
I mean, they filmed for two years, you know,
the preparation training
and like getting ready for that climb.
And I did maybe a half dozen sort of cutting edge free solos
to build up to that.
But still that's like seven days of soloing
in the two years that we were filming.
So you watch the film and you're like,
"He's a crazy soloist."
And you're like, "Yeah, for seven days out of two years."
You gotta keep it in perspective.
So you go from being, living a certain kind of lifestyle
to be the climber that you are.
And then you have this whirlwind crazy
like Hollywood year
where you're just on planes and going,
I mean, your life is upside down.
So I would suspect that the pandemic
for better or worse has kind of suited you
to like kind of get back to just doing what you do
and like being left alone,
so you can just climb and live your life.
Yeah, it has.
Yeah, I mean, so I live in Las Vegas.
And through the whole pandemic,
even during like lockdowns and shutdowns and everything,
outdoor recreation was always explicitly allowed
in the state of Nevada.
So combined with the fact
that there's almost limitless rock around town,
it was always totally okay for us to go out
and develop some new climbing areas
and go climbing and do things near the house.
And so it was an incredible place to live.
Yeah, I mean the whole pandemic
for me has just been sort of returning to roots.
You know, I have no obligations.
I go climb every day.
I explore new crags, you know, develop new climbs.
But it's like, oh, you know, it's not that bad.
And I know that's an incredibly fortunate position to be in.
Though it's also, I mean, I do live there for a reason.
It's like, I moved there because it's the best rock
and because of that degree of access.
And you're married now.
I am married now.
Yeah, that also happened during the pandemic.
But that's the thing is, I mean,
personally it's been kind of a good year.
But it's like embarrassing to say so,
because obviously there's been so much hardship
for so many other people.
But you know, sometimes things just work out in life,
and you're like, nothing wrong with it.
So how are you settling in?
How's Sanni doing?
No, Sanni's good.
Sanni is actually great.
Sanni is in a weird, like, I don't know
if podcasts listeners care about this kind of thing,
but she's like climbing really hard right now,
which has started this whole interesting
positive feedback thing where because she's really strong,
she's like more excited about it.
Because it's like more fun for her,
which makes her more excited to train harder,
which is making her stronger.
She's like in this total positive phase of life right now
where she's like really cranking.
She's like climbing her hardest grades.
She's all fired up.
That's cool.
Yeah, we just trained in the gym last night,
and she was like performing to a degree
that I was like, "Huh."
It's like damn.
You know, because I've been gone on expedition for a month,
and she's been basically just like cranking
for the month I was gone.
And I came home and I'm like, "Whoa."
Was she even a climber when you guys first met?
She had barely started climbing when we first met.
Her sister was into it and her cousin to some extent,
basically like her family got her into it a tiny bit.
And then when we started dating,
obviously she started climbing more.
Yeah, that's good.
Yeah, now she's like pretty good.
She's super into it.
Well, it's just like anything,
you get good at it and you get strong
and then you're more emotionally connected to it.
Yeah, of course.
You're more excited.
And I think for her,
you know, I don't know for sure,
but I think as she started climbing,
there was a little more fear involved.
You know, 'cause climbing is kind of serious
and kind of hardcore.
And I think that because she was dating me,
she kind of like went into the deep end right away
and was maybe exposed to like a little too much
of the like hardcore side of climbing straight away.
And I think now as she gets like stronger
and more able and can like do more as a climber,
it's all like much less scary.
And so it's like obviously more fun
when you're not scared at all.
It's like she's doing it in reverse.
Let's start with free soloing El Cap,
and we'll work our way backwards to the climbing gym.
Yeah. No, I mean, it kind of is.
Certainly psychologically I think that's right.
That's funny.
And there's some degree of luck involved
with it all too, because like, because she's been connected
with me for years and I know like basically everybody
in the climbing community,
over the last few years there were sort of
like a series of unfortunate accidents
where like people, prominent climbers died in various ways.
And so, you know, all of those sorts of accidents
like affected her personally in a way
that had she just started climbing in the gym
and not known me, she wouldn't know any of the people
and it wouldn't have like touched her quite as much.
I don't know.
That's the kind of thing that you're like,
you know, sorry to drag her into it.
This is the world you're in though.
Yeah.
Well, but there is a degree of luck to that,
because for several years it seemed like really bad
where like there were just a bunch
of high profile accidents that were kind of terrible.
But then you can go five years
and have nobody that you know die.
I don't know.
Yeah, but it's one of the few sports
where like what you just said would even come up.
Yeah, well, I don't know.
If you're road biking all the time, people-
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
There was just a terrible road biking thing in Vegas
that like totally shook the cycling community.
Oh, wow. I didn't know that.
It was like a truck basically
like drove over like seven cyclists
on a group run and killed six of them or something.
It was like crazy.
Oh man. I hate hearing that.
I know.
That's the thing is I'm always like, "Oh."
And you're out on your bike.
I've noticed that you've done,
like during the pandemic, you kind of have created,
we're gonna talk about Guyana,
but you've kind of created
these endurance challenges for yourself,
like I'm gonna ride my bike 100 miles
and then climb this mountain and ride home in the dark.
Yeah, that sums it up.
(Rich laughs)
Well, you know, because if you live in one place
and you don't have access to big mountains,
you can at least make the mountains
that you do have challenging in an appropriate way.
I'm gonna show up exhausted and see how I do when-
Well, I really love challenges that you can do from home
when you just bike out of your driveway
and then have this crazy epic day in the mountains,
then bike back to your home.
And you know, to be able to do that in the suburbs
in Las Vegas is pretty awesome.
You know, you're like biking along surface streets
just like, and especially in Vegas,
I actually ride on the sidewalk a lot,
which is kind of embarrassing,
but it's the best way to not get hit by a car.
I feel like a little kid or something
who's like afraid to bike in the shoulder.
But there are big sections of Vegas
where it's definitely safer to ride the sidewalk.
And you know, you're like, "This is totally absurd,"
but then three hours later,
you're grinding up this crazy hill, like a mountainside.
And then a couple hours after that,
you're like hiking through the woods by yourself.
And it's pretty amazing to have that kind of access.
So let's talk about Guyana.
You were like off the grid for like a month.
It's like this Nat Geo project.
Can you talk about that or?
I think so.
I mean, who's gonna stop me?
I don't know.
I'm not. (laughs)
Yeah, exactly.
No, no, I think it's all totally fine.
There's no network bosses that's gonna call here
and tell you to shut up.
Yeah.
No, I think it's all fine.
Yeah, so it was being filmed for an episode
of National Geographic Explorer, which I think is a series.
It was being filmed by some friends of mine.
And it was a crazy trip.
Yeah, so we flew into Guyana into Georgetown.
And then the goal was to climb this tepui,
which is like a big sandstone,
well, sort of quartzitic sandstone wall
that sticks out of the jungle.
And there are a bunch of tepuis
that are kind of scattered across Venezuela
and Guyana and Brazil.
Actually, have you seen the movie "Up"?
The really like charming Disney movie,
Pixar movie or whatever?
With like floating balloon house like over the...
Those are tepuis.
So that's like what we were trying to climb.
Wow.
or if you've seen the new "Point Break,"
that was also filmed in tepuis.
There's something like that in "Avatar" too.
No, the ones in "Avatar" are modeled
on this area in China.
That's like limestone.
It's like a different, it's caused in a different way.
Like it's a different geological process
that creates the "Avatar" mountains.
But yeah, it is kind of a similarly surreal
mountain landscape with dense jungle around it.
But anyway, so we were going to climb this wall
that hadn't been climbed.
And then we also had this sort
of renowned biologist with us,
this guy Bruce Means who had done extensive work
researching the frog species in the area.
So he was gonna sort of finish this transect
of the river basin that this wall formed the top of.
And he was basically researching different species
of frog along the way.
And so it was kind of a combined trip
where we were gonna get him up the wall
so that he could find some of the frogs on the summit
and possibly on the cliff itself.
So it's like adventure meets science experiment?
Yeah, adventure meets science.
Which is sort of the perfect Nat Geo thing,
where it's like adventurous
but there's a strong educational scientific component to it.
And why had those peaks not been climbed before?
So that particular peak hadn't been climbed,
I think largely because it's next to this mountain
called Roraima, which is, I forget what the name means,
but it's like source of waters or something.
Roraima is the, it marks the boundary
between Venezuela, Guyana and Brazil.
So like this one point in the middle of this big mountain,
it's the highest mountain in the region.
And then from that summit,
the water that comes off the various sides,
like one aspect drains into the Amazon River,
one drains into the Orinoco in Venezuela, I think,
and the other into Guyana.
But so basically it's a, you know,
imagine a big mountain that splits three countries
and splits the headwaters of three distinct basins.
So it's like this really famous sort of important peak.
And we were climbing the little peak next to it.
So you can kind of see why the little peak next to it
hadn't really had much action over the years.
Yeah, 'cause like people love Roraima
and Roraima has this huge history to it.
And like people were doing expeditions there in 1800s.
People are all about Roraima.
Nobody cares about Wei-Assipu,
which is the little peak next to it that we were doing.
And one of the things, I mean,
based on what you were sharing on social media
was just like how wet it was and just the condensation.
Yeah, I mean, technically we were there in the dry season,
but it rained something like eight hours a day.
It was like totally insane.
Every day we would joke.
We're like, "What the heck kind of dry season is this?"
It's like so crazy.
But technically was it a difficult climb?
Or it just hadn't been done?
It hadn't been done.
I mean, we didn't know, obviously,
'cause it'd never been done.
So we climbed this sort of large overhanging wall.
You kind of have to only climb the overhangs there,
because otherwise they're covered
in vegetation and water, which is cool.
It makes the style of the climbing really fun.
The rock is incredible.
It's some of the best rock on Earth,
it's like this amazing quartzite,
really hard, really solid.
And then what we did for climbers is a six-pitch, 12B.
So it's like, you know, hard enough
that it's like it's not easy by any means,
but it's not like cutting edge elite climbing either.
But for an expedition like that, it's pretty,
you know, it's solid.
We did something that we're proud of.
Well, you were there a month.
Did he find his frogs?
Yeah, he did.
Did he get the frogs sorted out?
Yeah.
So Bruce,
so actually he probably doesn't want too much said about it,
because I think he's gonna publish it all
in scientific journals and things.
But basically he left the jungle with many, many specimens.
Like he had glass jars full of specimens.
And then he'll take them back to his university
and do DNA sequencing on all of them
to see whether or not they're new species,
whether or not they're related to existing things,
just basically to break it all down.
But he was personally focused on the frogs,
but he also took many other creepy crawlies of interest.
'Cause basically anything,
the thing with where we were
is that no one's ever been there before.
So there's been like no science done,
because there's the rainforest approach
to get into the mountains.
But then between the rainforest and the actual mountain,
which is say three or 4,000 feet higher,
there's a big, steep, long hillside
which is sort of the cloud forest,
which is like if you imagine like stunted
kind of gnarly trees growing over the talus field,
like the rocks that would have been below the cliff,
it's like a whole different ecosystem.
And so no one had ever been through the cloud forest at all
in this area.
So potentially anything that he found there alive
could be new to science.
So, you know, I think he cast a pretty wide net
in terms of collecting specimens,
because like anything could be new
and it could all contribute to scientists' understanding
of that biome.
Wow.
So did you have to like bushwhack in
and were you camping out in there the whole time?
How difficult was it to actually just to even get in there?
Dude, bushwhacking does not begin
to describe the whole...
The cloud forest, we called it the slime forest,
because it's like, it was really interesting.
I read a couple of books
about sort of natural history of Guyana
while we were there, 'cause you know, it's the tropics.
So it's dark from 6:00 p.m. to 6:00 a.m. every day.
And we were staying in hammocks the whole time.
There's nothing like, there's no flat ground.
Basically the whole trip, there's no flat ground.
So you're always just rigging your hammock between trees.
And so I was in my hammock for like 12 hours a day,
basically reading books
and like, you know, learning and stuff.
It was kind of fun.
But it's just wild.
I mean, the cloud forest, there's no soil.
It's like, it rains so much that it washes away soil.
And this is particularly true on the summits
of the tepuis, like on top
of the wall that we were climbing.
It rained so much that any kind of earth gets washed away.
So you wind up with plants just stuck to the rock itself.
And then that means because there's no soil,
it means that the plants all have to get their nutrients
in other ways.
So the summits of tepuis have some
of the highest rates of carnivory in plants.
The plants all eat insects and things.
And then, or they're like big like teacup-type things
where like things will fall into the water,
collect in the bottom and drown and then rot,
and then the plant will absorb the material basically.
It's just like this crazy landscape.
So like crazy plant kingdom out of like-
Dude, I'll show you some pictures.
Totally insane.
Wow, that's wild.
And also the highest rates of endemism on Earth,
like endemic species, species that are unique
to that specific place,
because these tepuis are so isolated from the jungle below.
Because there's like a 2000-foot wall,
let's say sticking up out of the jungle,
the summits are a totally different climate basically
than the area down below,
because it's higher, it gets higher UV exposure,
more rain, harsher conditions.
And then the summits have been separated
from the jungle below for like 40 million years
or something because of the erosion
and the way it winds up being an island.
So it means that all the species have been diverging
for 40 million years.
I don't know.
So it's sort of like a last vestige,
Galapagos-type situation
where it's like a Petri dish for studying.
No, exactly.
It's exactly like the Galapagos.
I was about to say welcome to the Rich Roll Science Podcast.
I was like super, I got super into it on the trip.
I thought we were gonna talk about mindset.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Let's talk about biomes.
No, that's cool.
No, it was a crazy trip, but it's just-
I mean, it must.
I mean, you did that one climb
but like what were you doing for the rest of the month?
Dude, I read a lot of books.
And it's so grim being in the hammock for, I mean,
it's one thing, you're like, oh, you're in a hammock.
But like my hammock had a puddle in the bottom
for like the whole time we were at the wall basically.
Because we're in the cloud forest-
You're waiting for an opening?
No, we were just toiling away, you know.
It takes a long time to get to the wall,
and because we were filming,
because it's a TV project, everything's a little bit slower.
'Cause obviously you have to wait for cameras,
and there's just more equipment to move around.
And it's an incredibly difficult environment
to move equipment around in
because you're like literally crawling
through roots and vines and things.
You know, that's why we called it the slime forest,
because you're basically like climbing up this lattice
of roots and like shriveled little tree trunks.
But like I was saying,
because it's kind of a difficult environment,
it's not like the plants are like rooted in soil.
Most of the plants are growing on other plants.
So it's like, there'll be a tree trunk,
but the tree trunk is like covered in moss.
And then there are little parasitic flowers growing
out of the tree trunk as well.
And then, you know,
it's like there's all kinds of like epiphytes,
I guess like plants growing on other plants.
And so it's just like this crazy dense wall of life,
and you're just like crawling through it.
And it's like not an easy place to get around.
It's not like, "Oh, I'm walking on a flat trail."
It's like so grim.
Are there predators?
No, there aren't that many living things actually,
aren't that many animals,
because the whole place is like pretty tough actually.
You know, we saw birds.
We saw, apparently we saw sloth droppings at the wall.
So there were sloths there, I guess,
But we didn't see that much.
You know, most things come out after dark.
Like the frogs come out after dark.
We heard lots of things.
I mean, tons of spiders and snakes
and all kinds of things like that.
But nothing, you know nothing like exciting
when you think of the jungle,
and you're like, oh, monkeys all over.
It's like just not that kind of scene,
because we were kind of in like alpine jungle, you know,
like up high towards the base of the walls.
It's all like a little bit more inhospitable
than like a tropical rainforest.
Well, as somebody who's so environmentally conscious
and environmentally minded, to visit a place like that
where it's just bursting with life in a way
that you just don't see,
that's almost impossible to see,
what a unique, cool experience.
When you come back from that,
I mean, I know you just got back,
but that's got to,
kind of land as a meaningful experience
in terms of how you think
about all the advocacy work that you're doing
with the foundation.
This is what's at stake, right?
This protected place is what is at risk?
Yeah, so you mentioned my foundation,
the Honnold Foundation.
Actually this year we funded,
like last year we funded this project called the Kara Solar
which does solar-powered boats in the Amazon.
I saw that.
In Ecuador.
Oh yeah, you saw that?
I read the annual report.
Oh cool.
It's very professional.
I love how, speaking of professional,
I was like, man, you sure do your homework.
No, but so part of the reason I was excited about this trip
to Guyana and like climbing this wall was because, you know,
we had just funded this project in the Amazon.
And I was kind of like, oh, that's interesting.
And a big part of that project, Kara Solar,
was that by keeping transportation costs on rivers low,
like basically by enabling boats
to navigate these rivers easily without,
with low fuel cost basically, solar-powered boats
with electric motor,
it prevents the need to cut roads through the jungle.
And it was interesting because we did exactly that.
We basically flew to the most remote airstrip
and then took a whole day in a dugout canoe up this river,
which was totally insane.
It felt like an amusement park ride,
because there's so many big logs that fall over the river
that you're constantly ducking and like,
you know, avoiding vines.
And each time you go,
your boat barely makes it under some log,
all kinds of things like fall into your boat.
And then there are like spiders all over the boat.
And there's just so much life and it's so crazy.
But you know, I was like,
this is exactly the type of project that we were supporting
through the Honnold Foundation is like making sure
that this type of transit is economical
and functional so that you don't have to cut roads
through places like this.
Because rivers really are the primary means
of transit through that whole,
like basically all of the upper half of South America.
You know, it's like, there's so much water.
I've never been somewhere where it rained so much.
There's just water everywhere.
The dry season though.
Dude, it was crazy, crazy.
Well, those boats are really cool.
They're like these low slung, super long canoes.
And they're just tiled with solar panels all across them.
Yeah, solar on top.
You're calling it like the ghost boat
or something like that?
Yeah, I forget.
'Cause they're silent.
There's no (imitates boat rumbling)
like motor that you would, you know,
or the smell of the gasoline.
Totally.
That you would typically hear.
And more importantly,
you don't have to import the gasoline
or the diesel or whatever.
Because in these super remote villages
to get gasoline in there to power your boat,
first it has to fly in one or more small flights
and then take other boats
before you even get to the villages
at the very end of the rivers basically.
So it means that the cost of gas in those communities
is incredibly high,
because it's really hard to get gasoline there.
So when you can do something like a solar-powered boat,
it's just a lot more economical option.
So how many boats now are outfitted with solar?
I actually don't know.
The Kara Solar project,
I think they built a couple.
It was not quite a demonstration project,
but I think it was like,
they were creating this new idea basically.
And I think, you know, moving forward,
they'll just keep building boats
as demand dictates.
Yeah.
We'll be back in a sec,
but first, if you enjoy this podcast,
and I hope you're enjoying it,
then something tells me
I think I'll really dig my latest book "Voicing Change,"
featuring excerpts from, poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50
of my favorite guests over the last eight plus years
of doing this thing, this podcast.
It's a gorgeous, artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there in,
all wrapped in a hardcover, coffee table form
that provides a great taste
of what we do here at the RRP
and also serves as a beautiful keepsake
or gift or primer for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available,
and we're shipping globally direct
to any coffee table on planet Earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
Well, it's cool the work that you're doing
with the foundation.
I mean, the last time we talked was at that event in Denver,
that Rivian thing where it was kind of an announcement
about the project that you're doing in Puerto Rico
creating this community organized
and operated, micro solar grid
Microgrid.
Using batteries from the Rivian trucks, right,
as like solar cells-
Storage.
Which is pretty cool.
So let's talk about that a little bit,
what an amazing project this town
overridden by the hurricane, has no power.
I mean, how did you even find like Arturo
and like the people to like make that happen?
Yeah, that's one of the projects I'm most proud of
through the Honnold Foundation,
because it's just such an interesting
and potentially transformative project.
But so just for context it's in Adjuntas in Puerto Rico,
which is kind of the center of Puerto Rico,
which was pretty hard hit by the hurricane.
And basically, because it's sort of in the center
of the island, it was cut off, you know,
transmission distribution lines for power
were sort of severed for a long time.
So you wound up with the whole city off the grid
for like months after the hurricane.
And so sort of just as luck would have it,
that community has this community organization
called Casa Pueblo, which has already done
sort of environmentally-focused community organizing
for many years, like opposing a big mine
in the middle of the country and a couple other
sort of environmental advocacy type projects.
And they've always embraced solar.
Like Casa Pueblo has always had solar on their own facility.
And so after the hurricane,
they became sort of this energy oasis
in the middle of an otherwise blacked-out town.
And so I think that's a big part
of why there's such community buy-in in Adjuntas,
because they had months
where there was basically one structure in the whole city
that has power, and it's Casa Pueblo,
and it's because they embraced solar.
And so there's tremendous community buy-in,
and combined with the fact
that utility rates are really high,
people are basically paying way too much
for their power anyway.
So they're really open to other solutions.
And so Casa Pueblo is looking to institute a microgrid
in the whole city center.
So basically all the main businesses downtown could go
onto a microgrid and sort of separate
from the utility.
And the executive director
of the Honnold Foundation reached out to him,
because she heard about his work.
Dory.
Yeah, Dory, Dory Trimble.
She's incredible.
So she reached out to Casa Pueblo and was like,
"Oh, we'd love to help support this project."
And then we wound up wrangling Rivian,
which is a personal sponsor of mine,
the electric truck manufacturer.
They offered to supply the batteries for storage
for the project, because half the microgrid
is being able to store the energy they use,
and that's basically how it all came together.
Right, it's pretty cool.
What was really cool was hearing RJ, the founder of Rivian,
talk about how they've created this battery technology,
such that when the car has run its course
and people are done with it or whatever,
they can pull the battery out
and then they can repurpose it for this very thing
to like power these grids.
Yeah, that's exactly it.
And that's an important part of the Rivian design,
because some electric cars
haven't really designed their batteries
with the second life applications in mind.
They just make the cheapest battery they can.
And then when it's done,
it just kind of gets shredded.
So I think that when you go into the design process
with the intention of using the batteries
for something else useful after their life om the car,
that's an important, and really
that should be a design principle for all products.
Thinking about what happens to it
when it no longer can do
what it's designed for.
Especially when the mining,
the minerals and every, I mean.
it's so intensive now.
Totally, totally.
And the environmental impact of that is so traumatic
for the planet.
Totally.
But the thing that, I think,
the thing that, the biggest like personal thing
from the Adjuntas project,
I don't even know what you call it,
but like the thing that struck me the most
from the microgrid in Adjuntas
is that when you're in Adjuntas
and you're in the city center,
it's like a classic sort of plaza,
like what you think of, you know, small town America
or something with the city square.
It's like this bustling town center.
There are tons of cars, tons of people.
It's like, you know, it's the center
of this whole community.
And to power the whole thing,
it's something like eight Rivian truck batteries.
And so if you think of it as eight trucks
that are gonna power that whole downtown,
when you're standing in the downtown
and you look at how many cars are around you,
there are like hundreds of cars
parked on both sides of the street,
bumper-to-bumper going around the square.
It's like crazy, it's super dense, you know?
And you're like, "Man, eight of those
"can power the whole thing."
It's like pretty striking actually,
because Rivian, I think Amazon has already pre-ordered
100,000 electric delivery vans from Rivian,
maybe even more now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was a big deal.
That's like a huge part of Rivian's business
is gonna be powering the Amazon fleet.
Totally, but so 100,000 electric delivery vans,
and you think that, you know, all of those will be
sort of phasing out in 10, 15 years.
And it only takes eight of them
to power this whole city center
in a way that's like transformative for the community.
And you're like, when you multiply that out,
you're like, "Man, that's a lot of communities
"that could be positively impacted in that way."
And so that's kind of the exciting opportunity
for the Honnold Foundation, I think,
is to help establish sort of a pipeline
for second-life batteries
and potentially implement more microgrids like this
around say the Caribbean or something.
I mean, I suppose we should say,
you created this foundation, what like three years ago
or something like that?
No, no.
I made it like in 2012 or something.
Oh, it's been around that long?
It's been this slow-
It's kind of hit this stride
in the last couple years.
And a big part of that is hiring
the executive director Dory,
who's actually very smart and is,
because for many years it was just a way
of me personally donating money.
And so I would just, you know, donate some money.
It'd be split into let's say two grants
to two different organizations.
And like, that's it.
And then in the last three or four years,
sort of since "Free Solo"
and the whole crazy movie tour, it's really become
like much more of its own organization.
It started as your own personal
effective altruism experiment.
Yeah, exactly.
And then it's become institutionalized.
I think you guys donate like 1.3 million,
you had like 1.3 million?
Almost a million this year.
You donated like 87%, like a really high percentage
of what came in like went directly to projects.
And you've picked solar
as the primary focus at least for now.
So I have lots of things I want to say about that,
but maybe explain as somebody who's very, you know,
environmentally literate
and has spent a lot of time studying environmentalism,
thinking about it,
why is solar the primary focus right now?
So when I started the foundation,
like you said, it was just my way
of sort of trying to affect, you know, effective altruism.
So I was basically just looking
for any kind of, well, I guess,
starting at the beginning,
I think that the most important issue
facing humanity is climate change
or sort of environmental degradation,
more broadly let's say.
And at the same time, I think there's no point
in trying to solve environmental problems
that don't also improve quality of life
that like help the human populations in the area.
Because you know, I've been
on enough expeditions to various parts of the world
where you see communities that, you know,
like they'll cut down the last tree on Earth
if it means boiling water for their family
to keep their kids safe and things like that.
And the solution can't be premised
on us all being martyrs.
No, exactly.
That's the thing.
And anywhere you go in the world,
and it's funny, 'cause we're talking about Guyana.
Like we were just hanging with these,
all the Amerindian folks
like deep in the interior,
like basically Native Americans from South America.
And you know, a bunch of the villages,
they're living super traditional lifestyles.
It's like, you know, basically still practicing slash
and burn agriculture, cultivating cassava.
It's all, you know, as it has been for thousands of years
to some extent, and they're all like, "We want DirecTV."
And you're like, "You don't even have power."
Like there's no grid, there's no cell service,
there's no connectivity, there's no transportation.
You know, they have to take a boat
for a day to get to the closest town.
It's like so disconnected, and they're like,
"When's the DirecTV getting here?"
And you're like, "I think it might be a minute."
Like, you're like first you gotta,
there are a lot of things like,
first you need a metal roof.
You need to be able to keep stuff dry, you know?
Plumbing.
Yeah, totally.
General electricity.
So I've been on enough trips like that
where you realize that there are really humans
all over Earth, you know.
Even if they're actively trying
to preserve their traditional lifestyle,
like they still want refrigeration.
They want access to medicine.
They want communication.
Pretty much all humans want some degree
of material comfort in their life.
And that's only fair, you know.
It's like, I want to be relatively comfortable.
I want climate control,
at least to some extent.
I want like flooring.
I want to not get parasites, things like that.
Like I want access to clean food and water.
And so, you know, I think that when you focus
on environmental issues,
it's important to also sort of focus on the equity issues
of like, well, humans, like all humans should be entitled
to certain standards of living.
And so I think that if you're trying
to solve environmental issues
without also focusing on the equity side,
like making sure that all humans are equally able
to take care of themselves,
basically it's just not fair
to not do those both at the same time.
And so that sort of informed the initial projects
from the Honnold Foundation is like looking
for environmental projects
that also improve standard of living
that like helped folks.
And over the years,
we basically always wound up choosing solar projects,
because they just often are the most elegant solutions
to those kinds of problems
where it's like good for the environment,
good for people, you know, a clear win-win.
And then after several years of supporting a bunch
of different solar projects,
we were like, "We should just make this explicit."
'Cause at a certain point, you know, you may as well focus
on what you already know and what you're kind of good at.
And I just think solar is such an obvious solution
to many human problems.
Yeah, I mean, the sun is shining down
and beating us with all kinds
of power that we can utilize if we can figure it out.
And you know, what's problematic about that,
I mean, it seems like it's easier
to implement a solar solution
in a developing country than it is in the United States.
Like solar has been so problematic
and tricky to get implemented in houses across America.
Bill Maher talks about it all the time.
Like every show he has like a countdown.
He's been trying to get solar
at his house for like, you know, years.
And he's like, it's day 1000.
And there's all these like regulatory hurdles.
Like we've had a couple companies come out to our house
and do like an evaluation.
And there's always some reason why
it was just ridiculously expensive or way too complicated.
I just feel like it should be easy, you know?
My larger point is like why isn't it just like super easy
to get this done?
It is. I mean, I don't know.
I think a lot of that is personal experience
and depending on your home.
'Cause, you know, I've put solar on a couple of homes,
well, a bunch of homes now through the foundation
and then but my own as well.
And it's like super easy.
Is it?
Yeah, I mean-
I'd like to talk to you about who I should be calling.
Yeah, totally.
I mean, I've done most of that stuff remotely too
where like my home in suburban Las Vegas,
I was actually on a climbing trip in Wyoming
at the time living in the van.
I basically made some calls.
People went to the house, they installed solar,
turned it on, all worked fine.
I was like never even involved.
I just wired money online.
It was like totally chill.
Wow.
I think a lot of that just has to do with,
you know, where you live
and how difficult the system is and things like that.
But either way, I mean, in general, it's not that hard
in the U.S.
And I mean, and you see that,
because rates of solar adoption are steadily increasing.
It's all sort of exponential growth.
It's like, it seems to be doing pretty well.
All right, well, I need to revisit this then.
Yeah, you should,
because also the cost of panels
has been exponentially dropping
to the point that nowadays, you know,
the panels themselves aren't even the most expensive part
of the install anymore.
It's like the actual labor and like the racking,
you know, like the other things,
like everything else that goes into installation.
Right.
So what are the projects that you want to be working on?
What's the next level of what you're trying to accomplish?
Well, so we actually just closed our latest open call
for what we call the Core Fund grants,
which are sort of like the interesting,
like what we were talking about, Kara Solar,
the Ecuadorian Amazon solar boat project.
Things like that come through the Core Fund,
which are basically like grants around the world
for interesting solar projects.
So the latest round, you know, we'll probably fund,
you know, 10ish projects like that.
But we got, well, we got hundreds of applications,
and of those we probably had about 50
or 60 that are legitimately good applications.
But we can only fund the top 10 or so.
So really there's tons of incredible ideas
and good projects out there.
It's just a matter of having enough money
to actually implement them all,
which, you know, we've, as you said,
we gave away over a million dollars this year,
which for me personally counts as tremendous success,
because when I started the foundation
it was me donating 50K a year of just my own money.
So to see, you know, 20 times the impact as when I started,
I'm like, "Oh, that's awesome to do 20 times more work.
"That's great."
But then also knowing
that we could have a $10 million budget and still,
I think 10 probably actually would pretty much fill
all the things that we're seeing right now.
But, but you know, there are like hundreds of millions
of dollars worth of good projects out there
that that could be done.
There are individual changes that we can all make
to live more sustainably.
And then there are kind of institutional, social changes
that we need to see move forward
in order to really kind of affect the problem,
the existential crisis that we're facing.
And, you know, those personal changes can be
everything from composting to your diet
and where you buy your clothes and all that kind of thing.
One of the things that you said in some article
or someplace you wrote this I believe
that I hadn't really thought a lot about
but it's so obvious, which is like,
where are you banking?
Yeah, I wrote an op-ed about that.
Yeah, talk a little bit about that.
Yes, and actually I'll talk about that,
but then I also have some things to say
about personal choice like that also,
because so banking is pretty much the number one thing
that you can do for personal impact,
which is funny because it's so much less satisfying
than like changing your diet, let's say.
'Cause it's less obvious.
But the thing is wherever you bank,
they're using your money the whole time
that it sits in whatever account.
You put it into an account,
and then they're investing it in things.
They're spending it, they're using it basically.
And so, you know, a famous example is like Wells Fargo
with the Dakota Access Pipeline or something.
But in general, every bank, every major bank
in America is supporting both sides of the political aisle.
They're making political donations.
They're investing in fossil fuels.
Basically if you're using a mainstream big bank,
it for sure is doing stuff that you personally wouldn't do.
Whether you're on the left or the right,
it's like your bank is for sure doing stuff
that you wouldn't want it to do.
And so, you know, the solution there is
to do bank with nonprofit credit unions, things like that,
like local banks, smaller scale banks.
Just bank with a bank that is not going to be investing
in like fossil fuel infrastructure and things like that
that you might not personally support.
Right, is there a resource where you can go online
and get like somebody who's done like a consumer reports
on this where there's like a clearing house
of like seeing what all the banks are doing?
Yeah, I'm sure there is.
There must be.
Yeah, there must be.
So my sister actually many years ago
before I started my foundation,
before I started any of this stuff,
she gave me this book
called "The Better World Shopping Guide,"
which I think is out of print now
but at the time was this incredible resource
where for any consumer product, including banking
and things like that, you could flip through
and basically see all brands listed from A to F.
And it was eye-opening for me at the time,
because I realized I could go to the grocery store,
look at breads and see two different breads on the shelf,
same price point, same basic quality, except one, you know,
is basically actively supporting the type
of world that I want to live in.
You know, like paying its employees good living wages
and like providing maternity leave and things like that.
And the other is like ruthlessly exploiting its workers
and degrading the Earth and it's the exact same product.
And you're kind of like,
"Well, obviously I should support the one
"that makes for a better world."
And so yeah, "The Better World Shopping Guide."
My sister, she signed it for me.
It said, "For Alex, in case you ever start giving a shit.
"Love, Stasia."
Like it was a pretty classic, you know,
because especially when I was younger,
I was just all a little more like hard line.
I was just so focused on climbing.
Yeah, but you now, you're all about it.
Yeah, but that's the interesting thing
about like the long gradual awakening,
like you just learn more and you start to care more about it
and then it's sort of a virtuous cycle.
Yeah, well that keys into something
I think he wanted to talk about,
which is like this personal choice thing.
Yeah, it's funny 'cause I've sort of come full circle
on this a little bit,
because obviously I care a lot about personal choice.
I'm a vegetarian because
or like sort of aspirationally vegan basically,
personally because I'm lactose intolerant,
partially because basically just
it's a much lower impact for diet.
You know, I changed my banking.
I've changed all kinds of lifestyle things
in an effort to minimize my personal impact on Earth
and even starting the Honnold Foundation was to some extent
to know that I personally was doing as much good as harm.
Because just by living and traveling to climb and all that,
like obviously I'm having a negative impact on the world.
And so I'd like to think
that I'm doing as much good as harm.
But now I'm sort of coming back around to it
where I feel like the whole onus on personal choice
has been sort of foisted upon us by outside forces.
It's like basically industry telling us like,
"You should think about your choices"
rather than have the industry regulated
in a way that is appropriate.
You know, because even if
and actually COVID has been an interesting measure of this,
because even with travel lockdowns
for the whole world for the last year,
global emissions have only dropped seven
or 10% or something like 7%.
I mean, that's still barely in line
with Paris Accord type things.
And so if you think that all of human society
is fundamentally changed for the last year
and we're still barely hitting the numbers
that we pledged to meet
for the latest round of climate accord negotiations,
you're kinda like, "That's crazy."
You know what I mean?
It just shows the scale of this.
It shows the scale of real change that has to happen.
And that kind of thing only happens with policy,
because it's one thing for individuals
to like choose the right product all the time,
but it's another thing to just make sure
that all the products have to be made well to begin with.
You know what I mean?
Like eliminating pollution in different ways.
But policy is also a reflection
of popular sentiment, right?
Like if people are thinking harder
about their personal choices
and that becomes more important,
then culture reflects that and society becomes
or policy becomes a downstream kind
of reflection of that, like you need both.
Yeah, yeah, you do need both,
but it's basically like, that's like a chicken
or the egg sort of thing.
And I'm sort of arguing that I think
that it's probably easier to lead with policy changes.
You know, like in the U.S.
the adoption of electric cars and things like that
and like basically public transit
and changing transportation models,
you know transit accounts
for like 1/3 of our carbon emissions.
And so, you know, it's like an area ripe for change.
An easy way would just be to basically put a tax on gasoline
or something like that basically
on carbon emissions.
And that would drive all kinds of changes
in consumer behavior.
You know, rather than just hoping
that individuals will go out and buy a Prius
or buy a Rivian or whatever.
It's tricky though, man,
when you have legislators
who are beholden to their constituents
and the lobbyists that are well-funded
to push a certain agenda on behalf
of a sector of the economy.
And that's why these things move at a glacial pace.
And I feel like voter pressure
on our legislators is so important.
And that's why you do need to,
you do need to kind of take these personal choices to heart
and make them known so that there is that pressure.
Yeah, I agree with that.
But I know what you're saying.
I mean, just like you can't move the needle
on like I'm gonna go vegan
and this is gonna solve the problem.
It's not gonna work.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, I mean, you going vegan is a good step for sure.
But it's like-
The impact is tiny.
Farmers in Brazil will still be cutting down the Amazon.
There's a symbolic power.
Or like, when you,
you as somebody who so many people look up to
and you have a lot of people that follow your lead
and all of that, like there's meaning
in these choices that you're making
because there's a downstream impact
on how everyone else is gonna think about those choices.
A little bit, but I still think that-
I know you get a lot of shit though.
Yeah, well, that's whatever.
I mean, the thing is you get a lot of shit no matter what.
So it doesn't totally matter.
And, you know, and while we're talking
about getting a lot of shit,
like it's not like I'm just like advocating for gas tax.
Because I know that kind of thing is super nuanced,
because in a lot of ways that's regressive
because it affects lower income folks
way more than higher and that's not totally fair.
So it has to be very finely executed, you know?
It's like, yeah, I get all that.
I'm just saying that, I think that starting
from the policy side can potentially have bigger impacts
in the world.
Mostly because I think that, you know,
individual choice is great
for individuals that have the bandwidth to think about it.
You know what I mean?
And like, I have plenty of free time.
I read books about the environment and think about it.
But like the vast majority of Americans,
like if you're working a minimum wage job,
you are not going home
and reading books about the environment
to like think about minimizing your footprint.
You're struggling.
You know, like it's hard, I don't know.
So when are you gonna-
Basically, so I think that putting the responsibility
on the individual is sort of,
you know, most individuals are never gonna have the time
to think about it.
They don't have that luxury-
No, I get it, of course.
To reflect on that.
Of course, of course.
And it's not, it shouldn't be their responsibility.
Exactly.
When they're just trying
to survive, of course.
But in an ideal world when you go to a store or something,
every product would be justly made,
like fairly manufactured with no pollution
and like no externalized costs and all that.
And that's kind of the world
that I think most of us would like to live in.
You know, like you would like to think
that anything you buy will not be, you know,
exploiting child labor in other parts
of the world or something like that.
It is like an arms race though,
because I do feel like we're moving into an economic culture
in which people really do care about those kinds of things.
And it's incumbent upon these corporations to be transparent
about their supply chain
and how they treat their workers and the like.
And the average consumer
if given the opportunity to think about it
for a minute is gonna make the better choice.
We're good people,
and we all want a better world.
But these changes are glacial.
They're so slow, and we're running out of time.
So short of massive sweeping policy change,
do you, and as somebody who has spent,
I know this past year you've gone down the rabbit hole
on a lot of this stuff,
are you optimistic?
Where's your head at in terms of like how are we doing?
I mean, I'm personally always pretty optimistic.
And even I think, you know, optimism and pessimism aside,
I think that a realistic assessment
of global climate or basically a realistic assessment
is that my personal lifestyle
will probably be fine regardless.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm lucky enough
that I go climbing all the time
and if like climate impacts affect me
I can move to other places.
And so I don't know.
I mean, that's kind of the,
and that's the real thing about climate change
is that for most of us,
it's not gonna affect us personally.
You know what I mean?
Like anyone listening to this podcast basically
is comfortable enough that they're not gonna be the ones
that suffer from the effects of climate change.
It's like, you know, subsistence farmers
in sub-Saharan Africa that have crushing drought
and then have crop failures and can't feed their families.
You know what I mean?
But like, that's so far removed from our reality
that it seems to be like, oh,
we don't even know what that is.
So we're not stressed about it.
I don't know.
So, I mean, I don't know.
I mean, yeah, I'm optimistic
that humanity can sort of confront
and solve some of these problems.
But even if we do move too slowly
and it doesn't really work out,
I also sort of recognize the fact that, you know,
like realistically my life will probably play out
along a certain path regardless,
which is incredibly unfair,
which is a big part of why I started the Honnold Foundation
and things like that.
Because it's like-
Do you think you guys are gonna have kids?
Yeah, I think so.
That changes like how you see all this stuff.
Oh yeah.
You mean, 'cause you worry about the world-
Well, you just to start thinking, yeah,
your perspective is tweaked.
But the thing is like,
your lane is solar right now,
but that's an example of technology
that currently exists to solve these problems.
Most of these problems we have the ability to solve now.
It's really about, it's about political will.
You read "Drawdown"
and it's like, here's all the things.
Exactly.
If we just do all these things, we're good.
And it's like, why can't we just do them?
No, that's exactly.
I know.
And that's like probably the most frustrating thing
about reading environmental books is that you're like,
all the solutions are here.
It's like a buffet of solutions.
Like "Drawdown" is a literal buffet
of solutions.
There's so many.
Yeah, there's so many.
Yeah, let's just do five of these.
Totally, totally.
And so many of them are just such obvious,
and that's my thing with solar is
it's like an obvious win-win.
And you're like, "This is such a clear solution
"to certain problems."
And in "Drawdown" one of the biggest climate impacts
we can have is women's education around the world.
And you're like, "Well, that seems
"like an obvious thing regardless."
Climate aside, even if you don't believe in climate change,
you should definitely believe in educating women.
It's like, that's like basic fairness.
(Rich sighs)
Here we both like sigh.
I know.
Well, you know, it is frustrating
because there is a ticking clock here.
And you can say like, yeah,
your lifestyle probably won't be that changed.
But you know, if you live in Miami or you live in
like the low-lying areas of Southeast Asia,
this is a very real threat to you.
Yeah, though even last year in California,
the wildfire season was so crazy because of drought that,
and I think this kind of, I don't know.
I hadn't experienced, my family has a place in Tahoe
that I like grew up going to this like cabin in Tahoe.
And last summer, the wildfire smoke was so thick
across the lake that you couldn't see the other side
of Lake Tahoe.
And at one point I saw this like party boat
coming into shore that like a big, like tug almost
with tons of people on it like partying on the boat.
I don't really know what was going on,
but I sort of jokingly was like,
"Oh, look, it's climate refugees like escaping,"
because it looks like the ocean and it looks like a barge.
It's like the kind of scene
that you expect to see in Southern Europe with folks
fleeing North Africa-
From Syria.
Or something, yeah, exactly.
Like fleeing to Italy.
And, you know, I was kind of like,
kind of tongue in cheek and I was like,
"This is kind of true."
'Cause all these folks in California-
The sky is on fire.
Yeah, the sky's on fire,
and people were bailing out of the Bay Area
to try to come to the mountains,
but then the mountains were on fire.
'Cause the Bay Area was like crazy fire this year too.
And I don't know if this will wind up mattering
in the world, but it is interesting when effects
of climate change start to be felt closer to home.
It's like when you can't spend a summer
in California, people are like, "What the heck?"
That's crazy.
You know, especially, I've spent my whole life
spending summers in California
and kind of like, that's a first.
That's kind of unprecedented.
Yeah, I've lived here for, I don't know, 25 years.
And the fire season when we had the big fires down here
and had to get evacuated, it was bananas.
Yeah, that's crazy.
I've gone through fires, plenty of fire seasons.
That was completely another animal altogether.
Especially when you consider that,
I mean, fires are a natural part of the life cycle
of the forest.
It's like when you're in the Sierra Nevada,
you're like, "Yeah, this is natural.
"It should be fine."
And yet, you know, the sky is blacked out
for almost a month in Tahoe this summer.
It was totally insane.
And you're like, "That's not natural."
That's different.
Totally, that's craziness.
A different thing.
Switching gears a little bit.
Yeah, totally from environmental apocalyptic.
How much more can we dig into this?
Dude, I could talk about it all day.
I could too.
It's like super depressing,
but also super important,
or like this is probably the most important issue facing-
We need to be talking about it.
Yeah, exactly.
And if that just moves the needle with one person
that's a win.
What else are we doing here?
What's the point of doing it?
To talk about climbing.
We talk about climbing.
You are in a unique situation though
because you did this crazy climb.
Like, you know, how do you,
and your life is kind of devoted
to iterative difficulty, like continuing to put yourself
in difficult situations and master those.
But you know, it's hard to trump free soloing El Cap.
So like, what are you gonna do?
How do you shift gears and find meaning
in a different way in this thing that you do?
I mean, you've kind of already answered it.
You're doing all these other things.
You've devoted your life to these environmental causes.
There's a lot in your, you live a very big life
that is providing meaning, not just for yourself
but for a lot of people.
But it is, you know, just from the pure athlete mindset,
how do you get jacked-up
about another adventure when you've climbed a mountain?
You know, you literally climbed the mountain.
Yeah, no, that's a totally fair question.
And I think it's taken, I mean,
I free soloed El Cap, I think, in 2017,
and the tour was in 2018.
And so it's kind of taken me a year and a half,
but really the season is sort of the beginning
of like a real fire or like real hunger
for challenging things again.
And so, I mean, you're right
that nothing will ever trump El Cap,
nothing will be better than El Cap.
But there's still some other things that are pretty cool
that I'm excited about.
The world's a big place.
Yeah, exactly.
And actually a couple of things I'm excited about right now
are just at home like projects in Red Rock,
which is the climbing area outside of Las Vegas.
And you know, I mean, sometimes you just get inspired
by certain things, and you're like,
"This seems crazy and really hard,"
but then you're like, "I think I could do it."
And then you're like, "Can I do it?"
And then you have to find out if you can do it.
And really that's like the whole joy
of the process is the finding out like, well, can I do it?
Is it crazy?
Let's find out.
Right.
Am I right in thinking that before COVID hit
you were thinking of doing the Seven Summits?
Yeah, though that, I mean,
I still would like to in my life.
That's not really like a big climbing goal, which is funny-
I mean, that's a whole different kind of thing.
Yeah, I mean, for me that stems,
like I don't know if you've ever read the book,
"The Seven Summits" by Dick Bass.
He was the first person-
No.
He's kind of a non-climber.
He owned Snowbird back in the day.
He was a businessman.
I think he may have been oil or something,
but I think he was like a Texas businessman or something.
But he just got this like wild idea
that he wanted to climb the highest points on Earth.
And so he was guided on them.
And this is like before it was the thing
and people did it.
Anyway, it's a great book.
It's kind of like classic adventure writing.
And you know, I read that many, many years ago
and was like, "That's awesome.
"I'd like to do that in my life."
And now it's a little bit weird,
because Seven Summits is so commercialized
that real climbers kind of thumb their nose at it.
Like that's not cool.
But I'm like, I still kind of want to, you know?
But that's not like a rad climbing project.
That's just like a personal, I'd love to do that in my life
but we'll see how it plays out, you know?
Yeah, I mean, for what you do
to not climb the seven tallest mountains,
like why wouldn't you do that?
Yeah, I've climbed a lot of other mountains.
What do you think when you see, you know,
remember when those images were coming through from Everest
and it was like the,
there were just so many people up there
and it was like a traffic jam and?
Yeah, that's crazy.
No, I find that somewhat distasteful.
I'm just like, oh, basically that's just not the experience
that I'm seeking in the mountains.
And especially on Everest in particular,
there are ropes going the whole way up.
So everyone's just like clipped into a rope the whole way.
And somebody else has put those ropes out for them.
And so, you know, I personally have sort of mixed feelings
about like outsourcing the risk
and the challenge of climbing.
Like I don't want to pay somebody else
to put the rope up for me.
It's like, if I can't put the rope up myself,
I probably shouldn't be climbing it.
And not to say that that's a standard
that all people should hold.
'Cause you know, I'm sure,
and I think climbing Everest is really,
really hard regardless.
You know, I think that even
if you are just following the rope that somebody put,
it's still quite difficult,
you know, it's a challenging physical experience.
But I don't know.
I just feel like if I want to go up there,
I want to like actually climb something.
Are you gonna climb mountains?
I don't think so.
Why not?
I don't think that's my thing, man.
But you could.
I mean I could-
You've got the energy for it.
I don't feel the pull.
I don't feel like the allure.
You don't care about getting
on top of things?
It doesn't like-
I love getting on top of things.
It's not my thing.
I want to go like in the ocean and swim down.
That's not my thing.
Or swim across.
But I don't think about going up that much.
It's different, you know.
I went climbing a couple of times
with some friends and I was like,
"I don't think this is for me."
That's fair.
It was weird.
But mountaineering though might be a,
'cause that's basically like ultra running,
like trudging up hills.
It's different.
I like the idea of all these like FTKs
that these guys, you know,
like Kilian's running up these mountains
and seeing how fast he can do it.
I just like the idea
of like creating your own adventure
like you were doing.
Like here's this thing.
We have all of this here.
Like we don't need some, you know,
like race or event.
Exactly.
Let's just figure it out.
So one of the things I'm playing with this season
is a traverse of the entire range in Red Rock,
which is like this actually as the crow flies,
it's probably only like 10 or 15 miles like linearly,
but you're growing up and over all these different peaks.
And so I haven't quite pieced it all together yet
'cause it's incredibly complicated,
route finding and climbing.
And I'm climbing classic climbing routes
and then down soloing other climbing routes
and going up and down to tag the different summits
but also do a bunch of good climbs.
But it's coming in
at like 25,000 feet of vertical or something.
It's like a really, really big traverse.
And you know, we'll see if a man should do it
and how exactly it shapes up.
But I'm like, what an adventure
to leave your house and then just climb this entire skyline
that you can see from anywhere in town.
It's similar to the thing you did
with Tommy Caldwell, right?
Exactly.
What is it like 17 peaks or something like that
and like 20K of-
Something like that.
Yeah, actually it was funny,
because with these really long
and technical rock climbing traverses,
it's actually hard to quantify the vert in the numbers,
because GPS doesn't really work
when you're climbing vertical routes.
You know, like when you're doing sheer vertical walls,
your GPS will like ping you all over the place.
So it like messes up all the numbers.
So I don't know.
Have you had that experience?
Like if you go up really steep hills with GPS-
I don't go up hills that steep,
steep enough to do that.
'Cause basically GPS doesn't really work
on a vertical plan.
It's like more for like a horizontal.
And then the thing I did with Tommy last summer
in Rocky Mountain National Park wound up taking us
like 36 hours.
So all of our devices died anyway.
'Cause your batteries don't last that long
if they're tracking GPS.
Wasn't there like a, you missed a drop-off
or something happened-
There was a bit of a botch.
And you had no lights at night and stuff?
Yeah, well more importantly we had no pants.
So we were like at 13,000 feet in running shorts all night.
And it was pretty character building.
What has Tommy been up to?
He's like your main, he's like your main guy, right?
He's like your go-to adventurer?
He's one of my best adventure partners for sure.
Actually I just climbed with him last week,
like the day I got home from this expedition in Guyana.
Tommy just happened to be in Las Vegas climbing something.
So we managed to sneak out for a day.
But he's been doing some home repair.
He's like doing something,
but he's doing a plumbing project on his house.
Hasn't been climbing that much this winter.
But he's just such an incredible climber,
even relatively off the couch, he's just like,
he's done it his whole life.
And are you doing, back to the environmental stuff,
are you doing another podcast with the Washington Post?
With that, I'm not sure.
There's nothing official.
I might be and I might be yeah,
basically interviewing environmental leaders
or sort of scientists about climate change, I think.
Which if it happens, I'd be pretty excited about
but honestly sort of intimidated.
Because as you know,
most podcasting is just chit-chatting with people.
You rarely have to know a subject super well.
But the thing is you don't have to hold yourself out.
They'll be so excited to talk to you.
And they know that you're not, you know,
a PhD in whatever it is that they are.
And so they'll explain it to you.
Yeah, but you think you'd feel like-
And you're trying to be a cipher
for the audience anyway.
That's true.
But you still feel
like you should have enough of an understanding
to at least ask interesting questions.
Yeah, but you read books.
You'll be fine.
We'll see if that, I don't know.
Speaking of that, like on this deep dive
that you did this past year,
what have you learned
that you didn't know like before COVID
when it comes to the environmental stuff?
I don't know.
That's an interesting question.
I mean, so on this trip in Guyana,
I just finished this book "Energy and Civilization,"
this like Vaclav Smil's, like this super dense tome
about sort of the progression
of different energy systems in human civilization.
And it was interesting.
I mean, I think that book gave me an appreciation
of how long and slowly the transitions
between energy systems are,
basically like going from human power
to like the introduction of the steam engine
to coal fired to eventually, you know, oil,
like full-on fossil fuels.
It's just like each transition takes quite a long time.
And it's given me an interesting perspective, I guess,
on like our current transition to renewables
and what that will take.
And one of the interesting things I got
from the book was that, you know,
every transition has been powered
by the previous fuel, let's say.
So like the transition to coal use was like,
you know, powered by steam engines
and whatever else.
You're reliant on the-
The previous energy model,
which is funny because that's a common criticism
of renewable is it's like,
"Oh, well it's all based on fossil fuels."
And you're kinda like, "Well, yeah, because any transition
"is gonna be based on the previous system,"
which I found slightly heartening in a way,
because I've always found that like, you know,
it's a little bit of a bummer that
to build wind turbines, let's say,
you have to mill a bunch of steel.
And like that steel is all being powered by,
those plants are all being powered by fossil fuels.
And so you're kinda like,
"Is it even worth building wind turbines
"if all the raw materials behind it
"are being mined and milled through fossil fuel extraction?"
You're like, "Is that worth it?"
You're kind of like, yeah.
I mean basically-
It's like a necessary evil
of iterating to the next thing.
I mean, that's a big thing with the electric cars.
Who's powering the Tesla grid?
What's the carbon footprint of that?
Like, it's massive.
Though that though, I mean,
when you do the math on it,
even if it's all powered by coal,
it's still better than an internal combustion engine car.
So, you know, it's like, yeah,
it's still a step in the right direction.
But I think the takeaway with all those, you know,
sort of the messy technical questions
of energy transition is like,
you still have to take these small steps
in a different direction if you're ever gonna get anywhere.
It's like, if you're hoping to decarbonize a grid
or change energy systems,
it's like, you have to start taking some steps,
even if they're not perfect,
even if it's not 100% correct.
You have to at least move in a direction.
And an appreciation that these things take time.
Yeah. No, totally.
I mean, it's not that removed
from like athletic performance, you know?
It's like, if you want to get better at something,
you have to just put in the days
like grinding away, you know, training.
It's like, you know, some days you suck,
and you just keep grinding away at it and eventually,
you know, hopefully eventually you do something
that's actually meaningful.
Have you gotten your Rivian truck yet?
No. No.
When is he gonna start shipping those things?
In June, I think.
I just got an email that was like,
"Configure your pre-order blah, blah blah."
I figured it's got to be getting close,
because RJ started posting a lot,
like taking the trucks out and like yeah.
And I was like, "Oh, they must be getting ready."
'Cause like it's been underground for a long time.
No, it's happening.
I just configured my pre-order.
Oh, you did?
Yeah.
It's pretty cool what they've done.
So they took over,
like they took over like an old, I don't know,
Nissan factory or something like that,
like outside of Chicago
and like just retrofitted the whole thing
and made it like sustainable
and brought in like amazing chefs
and like used materials from the area
to recyclable materials
and wood that was in the vicinity
to build the whole place out.
Totally.
Have you been to the factory?
I haven't been to the manufacturing plant.
I've been to the headquarters, which is outside of Detroit,
sort of classic auto manufacturer, you know.
No, it's super,
I mean, when I went to the headquarters
for the company outside of Detroit,
it was like full-on vision of futurist.
It's like kind of what you would expect from like a new,
you know, technological startup started happening.
I was like blown away.
I had this VR experience there
where I was like in a room,
and I put on like a VR headset
and then basically like sampled an assortment
of their like futuristic ideas, like concept vehicles.
But you could like walk around the space with a VR headset
and like interact with their concept vehicles.
And I was like, totally blew my mind.
I was like, "Is this Star Trek?"
It's like, "Where am I?"
In a classic, like nice new facility with,
it's like just clean and well-lit and classy
with like electric trucks all over.
And I was like, this is so-
Right, like not what you think of Detroit-
Yeah, so futuristic.
And the auto industry.
No, it was like, this is the future for sure.
That's cool.
It's really cool.
Have you done any VR stuff around climbing?
Actually I'm supposed to be doing a VR project this year,
like filming in the next month
and then something in Europe.
That's cool.
Yeah, I think it actually has the potential
to be really cool, but we'll see.
Yeah, I had this guy Michael Muller in here,
who's a big photographer.
With the shark stuff?
Yeah, so he showed me his stuff.
Dude, it's VR shark tank.
It's insane.
Yeah, totally blows your mind.
Yeah, he actually, he showed me the same thing.
You put it on,
you're like, "Oh," it's like pretty mega.
Right.
And they're using it for like PTSD in people,
not just like an experience-
To trigger PTSD?
No, to like help with people's fear responses.
It's pretty interesting.
And so I was just imagining like that
in the climbing context.
Somebody who's afraid of heights
or like that's their big thing-
I think if somebody's afraid of heights,
they probably should not watch my VR experience.
I think that might be a bit much.
(laughs) I know.
But you know, listen,
to have that, like somebody who's not able
to ever have that kind of,
somebody who's in a wheelchair or whatever,
never gonna be able to have that experience
to be able to like feel-
Totally.
What that feels like.
Or even just a gym climber
who's just realistically never gonna go
to some of these places.
Like the guy that I'm working with on the VR experience
shot an Everest VR piece,
like a three episode, you know,
basically he goes to the summit of Mount Everest in VR.
And I found it incredibly immersive and rich
in a way that I did not expect.
Because I've read tons of books about Everest
over the years and then to actually be in it in VR
and to be able to look around
and like interact with the landscape.
I was like, "This is so much better
"than all the books I've read."
I was like, "This is crazy."
That's the future.
I mean, those experiences are gonna be there for us
in the next five or 10 years.
Yeah, I mean like wearing noise-canceling headphones
with a good headset with like hi-res, really good,
you know, not too like jerky.
And I mean like obviously the technical side
of it will only improve.
And you're just like,
"It's just so real."
It's getting there.
It's like, it's still not quite there,
but I feel like they're right on the precipice
of it just being-
Yeah, I've always felt like it wasn't quite there
and then I watched the VR experience,
and I was like, "This is pretty there."
And that's kind of what inspired me
to feel like it was worth shooting a VR piece.
So it was like,
even if the current headsets aren't perfect,
someone will be able to use that footage
on better models soon.
It's pretty incredible.
Yeah, that's cool.
That's cool.
So when you do that then like,
so if you were gonna produce that,
you got to get up on some wall
and then you have like some kind
of headset with cameras all around?
How do they do that?
No, it's the opposite.
So the idea is that the subject
like climbs through the frame.
So the camera's fixed in a certain place,
and it's like full 360 camera, crazy VR setup.
And then the climber climbs through the frame.
I got it.
And that's to apparently to minimize motion sickness,
because if the subject itself is the VR focus,
like basically if you're wearing the VR headset
and everything's moving around you,
you get incredibly motion sick.
But if, when you're wearing the headset,
you feel like you're in a stable place
and you're able to control the vision and like look around
and then you can just see someone doing an action
in your frame, then it makes you way less sick.
I see.
But how would they do that on a big wall?
The lights.
It's hard work.
Yeah, I would imagine.
You have to like rig a separate repel line
near the route, fix the camera to the wall
like near the climbing route
and then sort of center the camera
so that you're looking at the climber
as the climber goes up the wall.
The camera remains static
or can it move too?
Yeah,
the camera remains static.
It seems like they could do some stuff with drones too.
No, no, it's too shaky.
And the point is for the camera to stay totally static.
Because ideally I think for the viewer,
they want to be in like a swivel chair or something
or like standing in a room where they can fully move around
at their own pace and the way they want.
And there'll be something happening in the frame
that's like the movie.
But they can also just not watch the movie
and just look behind them
and like look at the view the whole time.
Right, right, right.
But I think with the Muller stuff,
it's his point of view,
like someone outside of the cages and all that.
Yeah, yeah. Different deal.
But maybe that's also why his felt so traumatic to me.
It's because it like makes you vaguely motion sick.
And like, it's all kind of crazy.
The trauma might have something to do with the fact
that he's outside of a cage and he's with great whites.
Yeah, that too.
It's unbelievable.
No, I think the climbing stuff
that we'll be shooting is sort
of the other end of the spectrum
where it's like more expansive, broader views.
You know, a lot of it is about putting somebody
in a position that they could never see.
Like the Muller shark stuff feels very
like intimate and tight.
You're like, "Oh my God, the shark's about to eat me."
It's like super close and seems scary.
I think the climbing footage is more about being
in a spectacular place
and having super broad vistas-
I got it.
Yeah, where you can like see the world around you
and then also witness
somebody climbing something totally spectacular.
Unless we get a great white to make a cameo.
(Rich laughs)
We'll just see.
Combine these two worlds.
Yeah, exactly.
Two in a day.
Shark climbers.
You're in a, speaking of production, you're in LA.
You're doing like "Leno's Garage"?
I guess.
What is that about?
I honestly don't know.
I just do what I'm told.
They're like, "We want you to be on the show."
So you're gonna go
to like his warehouse and like see all his cars?
Yeah, I think "Jay Leno's Garage" is where
he like chats with people about the cars.
And I think he's a car collector.
So he has all kinds of interesting-
He's kind of a car collector.
He's got like multiple warehouses
or like hundreds of cars, like crazy.
He has one of the craziest car collections
in the world, yeah.
Really?
Well, so I know nothing about cars,
and I have my scrappy van.
(laughs) I know.
That's why I find this so interesting and hilarious.
But I think there's something to be said
for talking about, you know, the utility of cars.
'Cause basically I don't care at all about my car,
but I care about what it allows me to do
and the life that it allows me to lead,
like being on the road and be able to climb full time.
And I'm sure that
or let's hope that that's a useful perspective for his show.
You know, where I'm like,
"Oh, it's not so much about the car.
"It's about what I get to do with the car."
He's got all these crazy antique cars
like steam-powered engines and all this wild stuff.
And he, like every weekend, there's this spot
that's not far from where I live,
where a lot of like motorcyclists
and car enthusiasts go.
It's called the Rock Store.
It's like a little bar cafe or whatever.
And it's like right where all these windy, cool,
like canyon roads are.
So he like drives past my house like every weekend.
And if you're just at the right place
at the right time, you'll see him.
But it's always like
some completely crazy car-
Crazy car.
That shouldn't, I'm like,
is it even legal to drive that thing on the road?
You know, like stuff like that.
So I'm sure it'll blow your mind.
But I'm just curious
like what that conversation's gonna be like. (laughs)
We'll see. We'll see.
I think I might be taking him climbing too or something.
So we'll just see-
Oh, there you go.
How it all plays out.
Right on.
Yeah, I'm psyched.
Out in Burbank somewhere.
Or in a climbing gym?
I think Stoney Point.
It's kind of historic climbing area like north of here.
Oh, that's cool.
But we'll see.
I don't know, like all things in my life,
I'm like, I don't really know.
I'll just show up, see how it goes.
I'll just have a good time.
Alex, you have a say in these things.
Maybe.
It's easier not to.
Honestly, my whole life,
it's like easier to just go with the flow with it.
And you're like, "Cool, it's all a crazy adventure.
"I'm just on the ride and see how it plays out."
During the whole "Free Solo" craziness
did you ever max out and just be like, "I can't,
"I need like a break,
"I gotta get out of here"?
I think I skipped one event,
like in the whole "Free Solo" film tour,
which was like six or eight months
of like nonstop scheduling,
sometimes two events in two different cities
in the same day,
like something in Chicago and something in SF
in the same day, which is like pretty rugged
when you add the flights in between everything.
I think in the whole tour, there was one event
that I was supposed to go to that I was just like,
"I just can't" and had to go into the climbing gym instead.
And it was only because either Jimmy or Chai,
the co-directors took it over for me.
They did the event for me that night or something.
But, you know, I felt like it was pretty solid.
But then funny enough-
You show up with a smile on your face.
I mean, just from what I saw,
you completely were 100% present for it.
Well, that's the thing.
'Cause I knew it was like a once-in-a-lifetime adventure.
You know, instead of looking at it
as like this heinous work experience,
if you look at it as like,
this is a crazy adventure that I'll tell my grandkids about,
like the one time I got to sample the movie star life,
then it makes it not that bad because...
I kept calling it my deployment to Hollywood.
'Cause I think that people being
like deployed overseas for six months.
And it did kind of feel like that,
because it was totally different world,
totally different scene.
You know, I'm being taken places by car service.
And I'm like, "I don't use a car service."
Like I'm not used to having like a fancy SUV
sitting out front waiting for me
to like whisk me to a hotel,
but I'm just like, "I'm just going with it."
I'm doing what Brad does, Brad Pitt or whatever.
I loved how North Face made a tuxedo for you,
which is pretty cool.
Is that where you got married,
did you get married in the suit and tux?
I did, yeah, same tux.
Yeah, classy.
And funny enough, the formal wear stuff like that
actually does get more comfortable
if you wear it more.
Because I've only ever worn formal wear like once.
And you're like, "Oh, it's so starchy and painful.
"and not that nice."
And then if you wear them a couple of times,
you're actually like,
"Yeah, it starts to break in a little."
I'm breaking out the tux like once a week.
Yeah, totally.
For the deployment.
Dude, at the Oscars, the tux was like so tight and crisp
that I felt like my nipples chafed
like in the way that you read about that
like with the marathon runners,
like if you're running 20 miles in the rain or whatever
that you start chafing in weird ways.
You had an injury at the Oscars.
Totally.
I was like, "Oh," like I feel
like I sandpapered my nipples with this like starched shirt.
It was like, this is heinous.
I'm sure you had some surreal conversations with people.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, Sanni too,
like my now wife had a, who was it?
He won best supporting actor I think
for like "Green Book" or I forget his name.
Viggo Mortensen.
No, his costar.
Mahershala Ali.
Yeah, Mahershala Ali.
He was like walking by and basically like said hi to me
and then was like turning to introduce himself
to Sanni or something.
And she was like holding little like appetizer pizzas
in both hands and fully just threw it on the floor
and was like, "So great to meet you."
Had this really nice moment with him.
She was like so charmed.
And then like he wandered on,
he had this whole entourage with like a crew.
And then as soon as he walked away,
Sanni's like cleaning up her pizza off the floor.
You know, but it was like, "This is my chance
"to meet Mahershala Ali."
So it's like just like food on the floor and "Hello,
"so great to meet you."
Just things like that,
it's just fun.
I love that,
well, the story that I heard
and maybe it's apocryphal was that Jason Mamoa
was gonna be giving out the award, but it was like,
he wanted to be, if "Free Solo" was gonna win,
then he wanted to be the one to like say it.
Yeah, he's a big climber.
He's a climber buddy
and all that.
Yeah, he's a serious climber.
So it was pretty cool that he was the one who-
Yeah, he was genuinely like, gave everybody big hugs
and super psyched.
He seems like a good dude.
Dude, yeah.
I mean, you know, I only met him briefly
through the tour, but super nice guy.
And he has like a really legit climbing wall.
Super into climbing.
Yeah, he has climbing walls at his house.
And so we went to his house and like climbed
with he and his family.
And I was like, "You're really strong for a very big man."
He's huge.
He's so big.
How do you climb when you're that big?
Well, you just have to be really strong and burly.
I belayed him in the climbing gym,
and it was fully, like it's like scary to catch him
on the other end of the rope.
'Cause he's so much bigger than me
that I was like, "I don't know what's going to happen."
(laughs) Like I can't hold this guy up.
Yeah, no, I mean, you know, obviously I caught him,
but I like shot like a cork out of a bottle,
just like shooting up.
When I caught him, I was like, "Whoa."
It was so exciting.
I heard this interview
that you did with Anderson Cooper not that long ago.
And he was, he was super into like hearing
about like your mindfulness practice
and how like climbing is sort of like meditation
in that it forces you
to be so present with your environment.
And it wasn't until you were extracted out
of that environment and deployed to Hollywood
that you actually had to like reckon with that
and realize like that's part of what I miss about it.
And you had to like create a practice
around mindfulness and meditation to kind of ground yourself
through the whole thing.
Yeah, I got into the Waking Up app
if you know that Sam Harris meditation thing.
But I can't remember if I talked about it
with Anderson Cooper or not,
but recently I kind of abandoned the app
and abandoned meditation.
'Cause I was like, "I just don't know
"if I actually need that."
Now that I'm climbing full time again
and outdoors all the time.
Now, you're doing the thing.
You get that in a different way.
But most people, you know,
they're not living that lifestyle.
Totally.
Well, I think for me personally, I was like,
I don't know if I need to practice less attachment
or like be less, 'cause like I already get very-
That's not your malfunction.
Yeah, exactly.
That is not my problem.
And I was like, if anything,
I need more reasons to like care more,
to like get amped up more, you know?
And I was like, I think the time that I spend meditating
could almost be better spent listening to like heavy rock
and like thinking about climbing projects
and like getting psyched.
So I was like, if anything,
I need to be more amped, you know?
You should create a counter-programming app.
Yeah, totally.
For the too mindful people out there.
I'm not saying I'm too mindful.
I know what you mean.
Because definitely,
I'm far from like any actual mindful practice.
I mean, a lot of it I found just as challenging
as anybody else to like stay-
But the activity is what gets you into that head space.
Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know.
I just find that hiking, like being,
I spend a lot of time by myself in nature
and beautiful places just kind of like wandering
and in my own thoughts.
And I'm like, you know,
I think that works enough for me.
Like I just don't know if I need to consciously spend time
during my day doing that same thing
when like I could just do it
through outdoor exercise basically.
Yeah, fair enough, man.
I think that's a good place to end it.
Yeah, let's go walk outside.
Lay down.
Cool.
You can climb up the wall
that's on the roof of the building if you want.
I might be able to.
I have to go look outside.
Yeah, nice.
Well, have fun with Jay.
Yeah, we'll see.
Just another adventure.
Every day you're like, "What an unusual."
It's cool.
You live a cool life, man.
Well, it's just nice to have variety.
Variety's the spice of life.
Well, good.
Come back and talk to me anytime, dude.
No, thank you.
Thanks, always a pleasure to chat.
Yeah. Nice.
In the meantime, check out Climbing Gold
coming into your podcast.
If you want to listen to a less professional podcast.
I don't know.
The thing I heard was super polished.
This is the thing,
like the new thing with like these
like really highly polished documentary style podcasts.
Like that's not what I do, man.
I'm old school with this.
So that's like, you're on the cutting edge
of like what is working and what people really like
to listen to.
More like the team that I'm working with
is on the cutting edge.
I am far from it.
Fair enough, fair enough.
Cool, check that out.
And Alex is easy to find on the internet.
Just Google him.
That's it, man, right?
Yeah, that's it.
Anything else?
How do you feel?
Just, you know.
Very good.
All right, man, peace.
Thank you.
Thanks.